puis il m'entraîne au bout de la nuit
les démos de mairie
emile et images au complet maintenant
bonsoir à tous les trois vraiment au
complet voilà vous êtes venus pour
parler de ce film star 80 même question
un petit peu pour tous les autres je
voudrais savoir comment vous l'avez vécu
vous de votre côté en tant que groupe
parce que la particularité c'est que
vous étiez un groupe lors de ce tournage
enfin c'est une super expérience mais ça
c'est issu d'une histoire vraie cette
tournée qui dure depuis six ans et là
c'est la consécration encore
consécration de participer à ce super
film est évidemment on prend du plaisir
on a pris plaisir à le faire et on prend
beaucoup de plaisir à le voir ce film
donc c'était un régal
parce que ça c'est important justement
ses fidèles à la façon dont vous l'avez
ressenti dont vous l'avez vécu aussi bon
aussi bien la tournée que que le
tournage vous découvrir sur grand écran
c'était comment s'est passée très très
bien parce que en fait une très bonne
ambiance et là avec tous les artistes et
est l'auteur avec patrick timsit et
richard anconina qui nous ont bien
conseillés qui est il toujours près de
nous pour nous mettre en confiance et
pour voilà pour que ça se passe bien
donc c'était assez facile en fait le
résultat sur grand écran vous satisfait
pleinement
résultat sur attaque ans immense
satisfaction surtout quand on se
retrouve au stade de france à la fin et
qui pour nous dans notre réalité c'était
vraiment vraiment vrai et que la
première fois dans ce que parce qu'on
est sortis du saas et conseillers on
s'est vus devant 85 mille personnes
c'était pour nous c'était quelque chose
de fantastique et puis je crois que ce
film va être va rester dans la tête je
crois que j'essaie de le placer à chaque
fois je crois que c'est une bonne c'est
une build oxygène que on a fait avec les
artistes thomas langmann et est parti de
foresti mais au milieu de la de la
morosité du contexte difficile c'était
aussi voilà le d'évacuer de retourner
dans les années 80 où l'ambiance le
climat n'était pas le même incomplets
on adore la scène on n'a jamais quitté
la scène depuis les années 80 j'espère
que ça durera encore longtemps ce qu'on
prend toujours autant de plaisir
messieurs riche et 1000 r ça fait pas
tant que vous vous baladez nous vous
avons suivi dans votre palais de la bhs
juste avant l'arrivée du dvd dans votre
boutique be pop juste avant l'arrivée du
gsm dites moi n'est pas une nouvelle
idée pour être bien sûr à côté de la
plaque encore toi là on a inventé la
machine à remonter le temps
les années 80 excellent super extra
franchement extra le fait de revoir les
tuer tous adhéré entendre sa move ça
fait du bien c'est un truc de fou
c'est très bien c'est rafraîchissant c
c'est un très bon film
j'ai pas été déçu du début à la fin et
un bon retour en arrière franchement ça
fait vraiment plaisir
super tu as très bien très agréable ça
nous a rappelé effectivement des bons
moments et des moments passés
effectivement il ya 30 ans à peu près en
arrière c'était très sympathique savez
bien la pêche c'est clair et dans les
années 80 chansons préférées des années
80 moi c'est patrick hernandez born to
be alive
c'était bond to be alive parce que je
suis de la musique aussi
quand j'étais plus jeune donc ça me
rappelle et physiquement des bonnes
parties de basse on a chanté
ah non là ça va être compliqué non pas
devant les caméras vous a plu le plus
alors c'est quoi de retrouver ses
vedettes des années 80 ouais retrouver
des vedettes et chansons et puis
l'ambiance surtout qu'on a plus
aujourd'hui dans les chansons qu'on
écoute moi il m'entraîne au bout de la
nuit